i saw him on tv with the cape tuning
laser beams
i don't wear a cape
on november 5th you're about to meet the
greatest warriors ever known
eternals assembled the marvel universe
let's finish this
we'll never be the same
are you a wizard like doctor strange i'm
super normal
[Music]
marvel studios eternal sweaty pg-13
november 5th tickets available now we're
eternals
for 7 000 years we've protected humans
from the demons
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere
until now
you hear that eternal's assembled
hi
hello hey who's your gardener
this planet and these people have
changed all of us
when you love something you protect it
for eternity
[Music]
marvel studios eternals what's your
superpower
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked
get tickets now